cardi b trolls herself after getting in
on the shake it tick tock challenge
if you're on the app odds are you've
seen fans of the rapper breaking out
some serious choreo to the k-flock track
which features cardi as well as dougie b
and bori 300.
[Music]
[Music]
you can't do it at home well on
wednesday the 29 year old grammy winner
gave it a go and busted out a move at
home and honestly
i'm impressed
[Music]
not bad right oh snappity snap snap well
cardi sure got a laugh out of it
trolling herself in the caption writing
lmao this is all i could give you shake
it
you crushed it cardi
you are dripping
and some of the musicians famous friends
think so too
girl what lizzo slid into the comments
with three fire emojis while bella
thorne wrote quote hahaha yes adding a
clapping hands emoji
yeah okay that's awesome as for k flock
he swooped in with three crying laughing
faces and one fire emoji
[Music]
cardi's latest instapost comes just days
after she gave fans a heavy dose of
cuteness sharing a first look at her and
offset's seven-month-old baby boy i
don't know i just get too emotional when
it comes to my kid
after months of keeping their little one
off social media the migos rapper
revealed their bundle of joy's name wave
set cephus
that same day wave made his debut on
cardi's instagram with these snaps
sitting in a comfy rocker dressed to
impress in a baby blue puffer jacket
matching beanie and white kicks complete
with an iced out chain
of course it's no secret that cardi
loves being a mama to wave and their
three-year-old daughter culture
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
love joy it's a
switch
it's everything so here's to cardi the
woman can do it all
[Music]
you